翻訳: Chieko Tamakawa
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
みなさんは 今日
帰る家がありますか
「ある」という方は
少し耳を傾けて下さい
この数字は何でしょうか
400万というのは
シリアの難民の数
6000万というのは
世界中で 紛争や迫害によって
住む家を追われた人の数です
第2次世界大戦以降
最悪と言われています
今日は こうした状況を
少しでも変えるために
大きな数字の話ではなくて
「難民を取り巻く
私たち一人一人」という
身近なところに 目を向けて
いきたいと思っています
さて
「難民」という言葉を
知らない人に会うことは
ほとんどありませんが
難民の置かれている状況を
イメージするというのは
簡単ではありません
そこで 私が出会った
ある難民の言葉を
手がかりにしたいと思います
難民になるというのは
朝 仕事や学校に出かけた後
そのまま２度と
帰る家や場所が
なくなるようなものなんです
と その人は教えてくれました
例えば このイベントが終わった後
突然２度と
帰る家がなくなってしまう
そういう状況に思いをはせると
どうでしょうか
そのことに思いをはせると
ほんの少しだけ 「難民」という立場が
イメージしやすくなる
かもしれません
今言ったことのように 私は
「難民」という 遠くにある
ぼんやりとした悲しみを
どうすれば
自分たちの身近なこととして
引き寄せることができるのか
ということをテーマに
活動しています
今日は 私が2004年から
つくっている
「難民ナウ！」という
ラジオ番組について話します
はじめに少し どういう番組なのか
聞いていただきます
日本で 難民として暮らしている
難民から
リスナーへのメッセ―ジ
という部分です
メッセージをお願いできればと
思います
「(難民も）皆と（同じ）
普通の人間だと思うんですよ
誰でも 難民になりたいと思う人は
いないと思うんですよね
その難民が発生した背景を
理解することで
難民自身のことも もっと
理解することができるんじゃ
ないかなって思うんですよ」
日本で暮らしている 難民の方の
声を聞いていただきました
「難民」と聞くと
背筋を正して 真剣な表情で
話すべきもの
そんな気がしませんか？
私は そう感じていたんです
でも 「難民ナウ！」というのは
そのように 日常とスイッチを
切り替えるのではなくて
例えば カフェ 学校
職場 電車の中
そういう日常生活の中で
難民に思いをはせ
自分にできることを
考えてみませんか？
ということを呼びかける番組です
この番組は
私自身の経験に
深く結びついています
６歳のころ
経済的な事情で 家族が
離れ離れになってしまいました
１年が経って
もうこのままバラバラで生きていく
そういうことが
決まりそうだった時に
母親が迎えに来てくれました
母親は 大きな借金を背負って
後には病気にもなったんですけれども
いつも ひとつの言葉を
言っていました
それは「家族でいられる今が
一番幸せ」という言葉です
この言葉は 私に
家族の絆がどれほど大切なものか
ということを教えてくれました
それから時間が経って
2003年のある日
１枚のチラシがきっかけになって
私は難民の勉強会に参加しました
そこで 難民になるということが
時には 家族の離散にもつながる
ということを知って
自分にもできることがしたいと
思うようになりました
国連難民高等弁務官だった
緒方貞子さんの活動から
難民問題には 「持続的な関わり」と
「メディアの役割」が重要だと知って
この２つのキーワードから
「難民問題を 天気予報のように
繰り返し伝える」
そういう番組を
つくることにしました
今まで 日本で暮らしている
難民をはじめとして
600人の方に
インタビューを行ってきています
そのインタビューを通して
日本に暮らしている難民が
言葉の壁やさまざまな困難に
直面していることを知りました
今日は その中でも
特に私の心に残っている
難民のお母さんの
ある言葉をご紹介します
「日本に逃れてきた私の人生は
もう台無しになってしまいました
でもそれは もう仕方がありません
でもせめて子供だけは
十分な教育を受けて
社会に貢献できる人になって欲しい
そして幸せな人生を送って欲しい」
そのお母さんは そう願いながら
日本語が十分にできないために
子どもの宿題をみることもできない
そして 難民申請の過程で
国籍を持てない子供がいる
ということに
深く心を痛めておられました
難民が直面する困難は
本当にさまざまですが
このお母さんの声にもあるように
子どもの幸せこそ
親の幸せにつながると考えれば
まず 「子供の問題」に取り組む
ということが一番の近道ではないか
そんなふうに感じています
このように 難民という立場に
置かれている方と関わるときに
一番大切だと思うのが
難民の声から始める ということです
私は 番組を始めるまで
難民は「可愛そうな人」だと
思っていました
確かに そういう面もあります
でも 例えば
苦労の末 東京大学の大学院を出て
日本と出身国のミャンマーの
懸け橋になる
そういう夢を実現するために
ビジネスに取り組んでいる
人がいます
東日本大震災の復興のために
チャリティのファッションショーを
開いている人がいます
日本語ができない仲間のために
日本語教室を自ら運営している
難民もいます
こういう人達との出会いは
私の中にあった
「難民」というイメージを
大きく変えるものでした
これは 普段私が活動している
人たちとの写真です
当たり前のことなんです
当たり前のことなんですが
「難民」という人はいないんです
「難民という状況に置かれた」
私たちと何も変わらない
普通の人が いるだけだと思うんです
でも私たちは「難民」という言葉に
縛られていると思います
その言葉の向こう側にある
その人の名前
その人の存在に触れると
その人の声が聞こえてくると
思うんです
そうすると
「難民のやってきた遠い国」が
「友達の大切な故郷」に変わります
故郷を知って
その人の背景を知って
その人の暮らしが見えてくれば
次にパートナーとしての関わりが
見えてくると思います
そういった意味においても
日本で暮らしている
「難民という立場に置かれた人」と
もっと多くの人が 直接出会う
機会をつくっていきたい
そういうふうに思っています
もうひとつ
活動を通して大切だと
思っていることを話します
今まで「難民ナウ！」に出て下さった
全ての人が
「まず 難民問題を知って欲しい」
というメッセージを残しました
私もそれは 本当に大切だと思います
でもそれ以上に
「知った後 どう行動するのか」
ということが問われているのだと
思います
その時に とても簡単で
しかも 素晴らしい効果のある
行動があります
それは「伝える」ということです
私は12年前に
このチラシを手にしたことで
人生が 全く変わりました
誰かが チラシを置くという
伝え方をして下さったおかげで
それが私に伝わったんだと
思うんです
それまで 難民との関わりは
ゼロでした
今は 生活の９割が
難民という立場に置かれた人達との
関わりになっています
どうすれば伝わるのか
というところから見直すと
「難民問題を伝える」
ということには
もっともっと多くのことが
できると思います
ひとつだけ 具体的な取り組みを
ご紹介します
今 全国の大学生と一緒になって
Share My Heartという
アクションに取り組んでいます
これは 自分の一番大切な言葉を
アラビア語で書いて
混迷を極めるシリアの人たちに
届けようというアクションです
最近になって シリアから
返事が届くようになってきました
思いが 伝わったんだと思うんです
いつ 爆弾が落ちてくるか
分からないシリアから
「友達」 そして「光」
そして「平和」
そういう言葉が
寄せられているのを見て
胸が詰まる思いです
でもこの取り組みが
現地の人たちとの 小さな励みに
なっていると聞きました
みなさんにも ぜひこのアクションに
参加して頂いて
シリアの人に 想いを
伝えて欲しいんです
そして みなさんの周りの方に
このアクションの存在を
伝えて欲しいと思います
日本は 難民に対して冷たい国と
言われています
昨年は 5000人の人が
難民申請をして
認定されたのが 11人でした
でも私は
日本が冷たいというのは
ただ 受け入れ数が少ないと
いうことだけではないと思います
「私は 砂漠で水を求めるように
日本の中で 友だちを求めていた」
これは25年間 難民として日本で
暮らしてきた方の言葉です
私たちひとりひとりが
難民に対して冷たいのではないか
と 問われているんだと思います
私は決して 多くの人が
難民に対して冷たいとは思いません
でも 私たちは
難民問題のことを知って
このままではいけない
放っておけない 何かしたい
そう思っても
忙しい暮らしの中で
そうした気持ちを
簡単に忘れてしまいがちです
だからこそ 「遠くのぼんやりとした悲しみ」
である難民問題を
繰り返し「伝え続ける」 ということが
大切なんだと思います
伝えるということには
価値がありますが
「伝え続ける」ということには
もっと大きな本質的な
価値があると思っています
声をあげ続けると
いつか どこかで
誰かの人生を変えて
それが 難民問題に
大きな変化をもたらすと
確信しています
一緒に 難民問題に目を向けて
知ったことを 大切な周りの人に
「伝え続けて」いきましょう
今日 帰る家がある人には
それが 求められていると思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）